[Music]
anything could happen in yawn you Annie
and I didn't know what Princess Diana
was you know I thought it was you know a
beanie baby or like a nice dessert the
only reason you have a neck is to
[ __ ] put your brain out up in the air
a little bit
a hips are why you sleep and they'll
come over and gel down your body hair
and steal your wallet what the [ __ ] man
and it was a full line all the way down
to his pubis or purpose you know all the
way down it was kind of public area we
need to legalize decent gas station milk
back in the day they had like two kind
of vegetables and then things nasty
Brussels sprouts and more Brussels
sprouts I think you know I got hair on
my bud and sometime I walk out of the
room backwards
I don't pet a cat at sunrise I'm not
that kind of guy you catch me doing
natural stuff at sunrise having an
orange juice you know reading a poem you
know going back to sleep I've been
dating this Russian girl oh now that's
the dark arts bro oh I like cruise ships
do because I like endless pineapple
chunks in the morning